So, why are American tech companies jealous of WeChat...
...or maybe even copying them a little bit?
It's because WeChat is very sticky.
Sticky.
You know, meaning users like me never have to leave the app to hail a cab,...
...or transfer money, or order food.
So, imagine if Tinder and Paypal, Apple Pay, Groupon, Yelp, Facebook,...
...Amazon and Uber were all rolled into one app.
That would be WeChat.
Payment is kind of key because that's how you keep people inside the app, right?
That you're turning your social network into a platform for other services.
So sort of the WeChat experience may actually be coming to the U.S. pretty soon.
Mark Zuckerberg announced his vision for Facebook Messenger.
It sounded a lot like what we can already do on WeChat.
We think that you should just be able to message a business...
...in the same way you message a friend.
Take 1-800-Flowers.
You don't have to install a new app...
...or enter your credit card again.
You just send a message.